okay
so again the first drill
he's going to push and i'm taking the
static drill
which is he's pushing i'm letting the
energy go through me
and it's just going down to the ground
okay
now i'm going to keep the ground vector
but change the back angle and he is
still doing the same
he's keeping his ground vector as he's
pushing
then we're going to move it
he has to go back and accept the ground
vector give me a little more please i'm
going to go in a little more
there you go and then he goes
and the key part of this drill is that
when i change directions i'm not
shutting it off to change directions
i'm here and i push it never goes off
give me a little more
and then he goes without it going off i
still feel the ground through him
and he still feels the ground through me
so if he's pushing
he's just going into the ground he's not
going to i'm going to shut it off so you
can see the difference
okay or i'm going to have tension
unnecessarily in my body and he pushes
and my legs will come up i'm just here
and we're just hanging out here all day
and then i'll change direction
[Music]
it stayed on on him and it stays on on
me
stays on on me that's drill one
drill two i
have that same connection his ground
his center into his hands my ground into
my center into my hands
okay we're gonna go drill one okay here
then in and then percussively
boom
as i do drill two it's important that he
does not shut his off
i want a good resistance
that i can trade myself with so
it's on and boom
and as i go you can up
the tension okay so he's upping the
tension
boom and i'll try to make my move
boom smaller and smaller
and make sure my hands are not going in
and out
and more relaxed
smaller and smaller
okay okay so uh drill one is just
uh not to shut it at all
but there's an absorption that happens
okay
so as i'm doing it externally though
so as he brings me back that
has his energy coming in and that's what
i use to displace
okay oh absorb
boom and the smaller i make that
the closer i'm gonna be to drill three
okay
so um i'm gonna go this time i'm gonna
start going forward
i'm gonna go forward and then he comes
back
and i take that in so he comes in
the other one i was young
pushing on this one he's coming
in and i'm hitting that ground do you
get it
okay so in boom
okay so again there's still
a disequilibrium formula
so it's still based on basin support
center of gravity line of gravity
okay i can't go over the top of his
center of gravity because then his line
of gravity is not getting displaced
and i can't go in front of his center of
gravity because
the line of gravity is not being
displaced outside
of the base of support so when he pushes
i still have to move that
center of gravity enough outside the
base of the support
so the line of gravity falls outside the
base of support
so even if so he goes to push
and i go over i did get some projection
but
it was going over it doesn't move the
center of gravity enough
let's say i'm on the line but i do a
little one it doesn't it's not going to
do it okay
i have to be able to get enough
of a projection on the center so that
the line of gravity moves over
okay so the beginner usually uh
is trying to reduce the resistance so
the person comes in they're like whoa
that's
heavy and then they try to reduce the
resistance
that's not what you want so you want
that heaviness
pull that's the thing you want to push
on
boom
okay that thing you want to push on okay
try
so like you're going to start and you're
going to think
oh i i have his elbows locked out and
then i'm pushing
his elbows down okay so we got we have
to understand that's not what's
happening on you you can't do it you can
do that same move
but the engine is different so we're
going to do it
we're now going to do the same last two
drills but
from the
the side so i'm not gripping him
i'm here okay so he's gonna push me back
boom and then i'm gonna push him
say he pushed me back and then actively
so i don't grip this this is the eye key
application
of the same koku expression
okay try i start forward he starts back
and then he comes forward and he and he
hits that
you can change direction
it's the same thing so i'm not
struggling here he he's just going into
the he's just going into the ground
he's pushing i'm not leaning on him
he he's just stabilizing me every
everything's relaxed okay
well i'm gonna first change the angle
slightly
so that he starts to tilt do you get it
so it's going to go here boom and then
here is where he hits the
in space at this new vector
so just like in the other drill um
when he came forward boom he hits that
space
he's gonna hit that space over here
boom is where it hits it do you get that
it's not
it's not me going like this that's not
what's happening
okay so it's here like this i'm going to
clear the line
i'm going to bring this over here
foaming that spot
okay so the harder just like the same
thing
the harder he's pushing the more stable
i become
so the same thing the harder he's
pushing
the more he goes into the position you
see that
then my arm moves to stay with him
so it's not me manipulating him
you see it's just another cookie
projection
okay let's try this step okay so you
have an
external understanding of
you so he's he's pushing
and then i'm going to externally yield
do you understand but there's an
internal understanding of it too
so that's what we're doing here so
uh when when he pushes into me
i'm letting that energy go to the ground
he pushes into me and it goes through me
to the ground
you see do you understand that concept
okay
so uh when he's coming
through me i start with an external
just to create a geometry where the line
of gravity
and the base of support is going to
lead to a geometry of falling but i'm
not
going and doing that
you pay attention so he's going to have
his aggressive action he has his
displacement copper
that's the energy that i used
he's off my arm is going up
as he's going out not my arm
is making him go with his weights on me
do you understand that difference so he
he hits he's going to hit boom that spot
and at the angle he's at it creates the
topsy-turny effect
it's not me going here and moving him
with my inner shoulder and having
external leverage advantage it could be
a leverage advantage wouldn't be strong
enough
it might not be it's like the boulder's
big enough
my stick might not be enough to move the
boulder
okay this is the internal
so he goes
and my arm stays up with him so
[Music]
if you pay attention where he hits it
he's got a hit at the bottom
boom
not here
[Music]
yes my arm comes around but there's no
weight on it there's no weight on it now
he's
going back to the other two drills okay
i would say that the first one is about
just not having on and off
this would be a mindfulness problem
coordination
problem okay and then i just wanted to
make sure you have the the correct
vector so
in here and then i wanted it percussive
boom
but the next one is more closer to what
we do in aikido that is that his
energy's coming in
boom and he hits that part and then
again
i wanted it home for
the other two drills were just to try to
help so home
that i'm not it's not group dependent
it's not joint dependent
okay um so now we're in the technique
and i need those lessons
it's not group dependent it's not joint
dependent
and it's relative to how much energy i
let in
i have to let it in okay and so the
beginner mistake is to always keep it up
and keep it out like that okay and then
you don't
have any rebounding because you didn't
let the energy in
and in fact you're contesting the energy
that's coming out
okay so when i go here i want
i want him to go in and hit
that vector do you understand and how
far he goes out
is dependent upon how much i let in
how much young there is is depending on
how much yin there is
so when you try to get him to go further
out don't make the mistake
and do more yaw you have to do more yin
okay
so we're going and i'm bringing his
weight
onto me and he'll bounce off
so i'm exaggerating it with my arm as
you can tell right so i want him to come
into me
and i wanted to hit that ground vector
at that angle
[Music]
the difference is is whether this arm's
pushing
or whether this arm was letting his
energy still come in
boom and he hits that spot
so boom boom
okay let's go try it again okay so
the question was on the first two girls
how do you not uh so he goes
forward how do you not let that happen
it's happening because at the beginning
to
create the organization you tense
everything up
okay and what to continue to advance
you don't want that it's fine in the
beginning
to have a solid organization
but as you get going that's too much to
ask of marshally
it's not really what you want to do
anyways because it reduces the yin
absorption you understand that so you
can't project because
you're too flexed you're over organized
for example and there's not enough ian
absorption so the yam
release is not as great as it could be
so all you really need
is whatever contact point you have
through that center of your body maybe
not even that
but then a relationship of a greater
mass
okay so um
for example as as i'm here
you could you could be in very
awkward positions and i can still
find the movement
so you can still do it
um so if i
am here okay this seems very weird
but my right uh big toe
and part of the right ball of the foot
is able to ground vector so he's going
to push
and you see if you feel that we're not
going anywhere so with that
i can absorb to it and then get the
rebound
do you understand so
uh as you get more advanced you have to
start reducing more and more and more
and more minimum
things okay so um
meaning i'm not going to over flex i'm
not going to capture
the cochu aspects in an
over flexion of every part of my
do you understand okay so for example
um when we're doing the technique
uh you come here you come like this
right and you look
that you have to have that elbow up
becomes like almost like a fetish
um but you can still do you can do the
technique you see when i
if he hits the ground here it'll do the
same thing it'll
bounce him out can you can you see that
so for another words
he's i'm going to demonstrate it
externally so
his body comes in he hits that and it's
pushed
out okay well you can do the same thing
he's going to come down he hits that and
he goes out do you understand
okay so i don't have to do it
in this shape you can do the same thing
boom did the same thing you see how i
did that
you see that okay so the same thing
he comes he comes in and i don't have to
be
in that perfect posture okay it's not
necessary i don't have to be thinking
something
i don't have to be controlling my breath
i don't have to do any of
those are beginner tools but in order to
get out of beginner land
you have to start taking away the pieces
because the more pieces like a jenga
tower
i don't need that to hold the tower i
don't need that to hold the tower i
don't need
the more i can do that the more yin
absorption i can have
then the more young projection i can
have okay